[Music]
street fighter 6 is playable here at
summer game first 2022 our key three as
time has so rightfully pointed out um we
have been on the show floor tam has just
put in a good hour uh on the game and
you've got your phone there yeah so i've
got i've got some notes that i want to
refer to just because i don't want to
get bodied in the qrts
by the fighting game people so as a
general overview of what we got to
experience first things first the
adventure single player mode is not
available to play um so none of the open
world stuff that we saw in the trailer
is is was testable um what i did get to
play was a bunch of rounds with uh
someone who works at capcom um four
characters were available ryu chun-li
luke
and
what was the other guy's name
jamie thank you jan ochoa of
giantbomb.com um and my overall
impressions are i really really really
enjoyed it i'm sure as you can attest i
was very focused on the game i was going
at it with it with the other person
playing with me i think the the reason i
enjoy it um it's gonna take a little bit
of going back to street fighter 5 and
putting that into context the main thing
about street fighter 5 which has come a
long way um over multiple multiple years
and is a much better game now than it
was at launch but the initial launch
problems beyond the technical stuff
around network issues is from a design
perspective it was very rigid there were
not a lot of defensive options
and it was almost like fighting game
players would call it a flow chart um at
the time people were calling it turn
based and what that means is you would
usually do a number of things and the
other person would wait and either the
the incoming attacks would work and
you'd have to respond to that or you'd
block and then once they were done you'd
have your goal it was kind of like a
very slow gamer chest but with far less
pieces and far less room to move
and the reason that was that way was
because you didn't have a lot of options
available to you
you don't have a lot of defensive
options and you don't have a lot of
offensive options
so
pretty much every
game at a high level played out in the
in the same way so that lack of
character freedom and player expression
kind of bogged the game down this game
immediately feels way more open you you
see more tools um and and like you've
got things it's been detailed a bunch so
forgive me if i cause make any mistakes
here but you've got drive impact which
is basically a
for for people who have familiarity with
street fighter street fighter 4
specifically it's a fully
charged focus attack um and that
basically means that you you kind of
draw up a load of power and then it
absorbs an incoming attack and if you
land it it leaves them in a crumpled
state so then another player can the
player who's successful with it can then
follow up with more attacks the good
thing about that is is there's a counter
to it which is the other player if they
see the drive attack coming in they can
drive impact coming in they can
immediately initiate their one and it
becomes like a a kind of a game of like
uh out doing the other person um but you
kind of have to have an awareness around
you um there's also a drive parry which
for people who have seen evo moment 37
will know it's that kind of thing it's
not as strict it's not as strict on
timing as a third strike but it does
have that same kind of defensive option
available to you it's got a quite a lot
of frames of recovery so you won't be
like tapping forward to like do it you
have to hold down two buttons you can
you can tap them if you know that it's
going to be like an overhead coming like
a jumping overhead or you can hold it if
you feel like as a flurry of attacks but
obviously like it's there's an animation
to it it's very obvious when it's
happening so another player can bait it
out the interesting thing is if you do
that you can actually rush out of it
which is like a run and it's like almost
like a half screen run so a thing that i
was doing a lot was um
using the parry
in
at distances where it was very obvious
it wasn't gonna work so my opponent
thought oh he screwed this up but what i
was actually doing was trying to make
them think i screwed it up so that they
would start moving forward and then i
would rush out of it into throw range
and grab them so it was like a little
bit like of a meta game mind game and
obviously the other player realized i
started doing that too much and adjusted
and would like start baiting that out of
me um and then you have an overdrive arc
which is again for people with familiar
it's just an ex version so certain moves
that you can do that are powered up like
a hadouken you can press it with two
buttons and overdrive arc version um and
it will it will be more powered up and
then finally there's the uh drive
reversal which is a standard just
reversal attack um similar to something
like uh the alpha series or the zero
series um and that's a lot of options
available to you but importantly it's
all governed by a drive meter
so each thing costs like between one two
maybe like three bars depending on what
you're doing and
it kind of fills up as you um over time
as you like play the game the
interesting thing about it is you have
to be very careful in managing it
because if you use all of it you enter a
state that's called burnout which is
basically your character is tired and
they cannot do any of that stuff so this
is a period where none of those uh kind
of mechanics are available to you and
you have to wait a sec time as your like
stamina recovers so you have to be very
careful about how you're managing your
meter um which is where a lot of the
strategy comes in and this is where a
lot of the mind games are going to be
able to come in because you as a player
can look at your own kind of me and be
like this is what i can do the other
player will be looking at your meter
being like these are my the things that
are threatened threats to me and then
you can do the same to the other player
if you think of it as like a a painter
like you've got way more colours to work
with and you can create a much more
interesting vibrant picture out of it
the interesting thing about it is when
you're playing you feel like you're more
engaged you feel like you've got more to
think about in any moment but also
crucially when you're watching
there's way more
excitement in watching um obviously
street fighter is a big esport it's a
competitive game and over time like
street fighter 5 was not super fun to
watch because you knew exactly what was
going to happen and some would argue
yeah that just puts the kind of emphasis
on the player but even players found
themselves not being able to express
themselves you know punk played the same
as
justin with a certain character to a
degree um these now watching this stuff
it's much harder to predict what's going
to happen like good players eventually
will be able to like think about what
options are available and the likelihood
of it coming out but right now in the
early stages like it's harder to
kind of like predict it and see a flow
chart emerging
and that's incredibly exciting
ryu and chun li and they have new moves
that are like special
style moves that are given more like
range and options up close replays
really well i feel like in terms of
pacing it's somewhere between
four and five
in that it doesn't feel the characters
have a heft to them um but they don't
feel slow and bogged down they can move
around quite a lot i think the most
important thing though beyond the
gameplay mechanics is
it's like aesthetically really really
pleasing
there's a lot of like color there's a
vibrancy to it and it doesn't feel as
like
sterile if you know what i mean as as
like a uh
355 looked nice but it was also very
like
sterile and like it felt like a very
intentionally packaged game this feels
like it's got a vibe it's got an
aesthetic it's got a like a a a pomp
pomp and circumstance to like a bombast
to it um there's things like characters
walking in together and then fighting
they've got the soul calibur 2 thing
where it's like when your two characters
are facing each other you can move
directions and they all like have
different circumstances
they'll have different facial
expressions and like you can do that for
a bit there's like three different
taunts um everyone is like expressing
when they take a punch you can see them
grimacing and that kind of stuff the
music is really really like um
kind of like upbeat at times and there's
a kind of energy to it that feels really
good and it reminds me a lot of um
defining quality that early capcom games
had like games like capcom vs snk 2 it
had a a definite vibe to it street
fighter 4 had a vibe to it it had like a
a theme running to it the idea of a
comeback when street fighter 4 was
released it was a comeback for that for
that game third strike had a hip-hop
jazz vibe to it this feels like it's got
a
street fighting vibe where it feels like
a bunch of people out there in the world
fighting it's scrappy it feels like you
know it doesn't have like the street
fighter 5 felt like esports like
everyone's in these like arenas and
there's like a like geared like made
purpose exactly this doesn't feel like
that it feels like a bunch of weirdos
for some reason are beating the crap out
of each other on the road there's people
and there's so much like capcom kind of
like uh
easter eggs in there as well there's one
point i was like is that poison is that
hondo is that like the mad gear gang guy
standing in the background and i am very
very excited to play more of it like
inside the lab monster in me was like i
just wanna i immediately said can we go
into practice mode and they were like no
we can't do that yet it's not
functioning um and like i was just
desperate to keep getting playing more
and more and more uh and and like yeah i
just want to sit down with it and spend
a lot of time with it and play more and
figure things out but
so far so good it's early days obviously
take everything with a grain of salt
it's a limited slice it's every all the
usual caveats for a preview i am high on
playing street fighter so maybe like a
few days from now i'd be like actually
maybe not but like as it stands in the
heat at the moment you know i played it
an hour ago i'm very very optimistic
about
getting something that at least as a
starting point is really really going to
be uh rewarding to play and hopefully
capcom continues to build on it um but
they have introduced me mechanics over
the over the time a street fighter game
has been out in the last few iterations
so
as a baseline street fighter 6 feels way
more interesting to me than three five
five and i'm i can't wait to play more
yeah and now unfortunately you do have
to go back and play three five five yes
while you wait for six i think i'm just
gonna leave three five five like i'm
just gonna wait i'm just gonna wait for
the new one like i've had my i've had my
time with it i'm going to make my piece
with it and just prepare myself for the
new the new generation mentally mentally
and physically i'm hitting the road with
like ryu i'm going to take my socks and
shoes off walk that pavement with my
bare feet get real sweaty and
wide thank you for ending on that note
we're gonna have a bunch of gameplay of
street fighter 6 on gamespot.com
youtube.comgamespot so make sure to
stick around if you want to watch some
of that tam's probably going to do some
more stuff on street street five six in
the in the coming days weeks
so keep an eye peeled for that as well
and uh for everything else to do with
key three summer game first keep a game
spot